hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Taylor
Bradley we caught up and Taylor is she's
actually a very creative person so I
thought you know what I haven't been
catching up with movie trailers a lot
too often and for someone who does a lot
of writing and acts too I thought she'd
be perfect
so we're gonna start off with a trailer
that dropped called strange little
stranger land it stars Nicole Kidman who
you guys know from The Stepford Wives
and if you go weaving who you might know
from babe a pig in the city I'm kidding
I know they got bigger roles out there
all right no idea what this is about
Nicole Kidman's in it it's gonna be good
she's somewhere
hi Daddy which is some clothes on
Lily's been missing before
hello daughters a [ __ ]
I reckon that girls are gonna tell you
something why did you go ahead and let
another
why are you doing
[ __ ] speaker this speaker keeps
pissing me off this is really intense
and I'm really confused to go out in the
middle with an arm
why are you doing
did you meet someone better economy but
I get intense uh it looks intense okay
your worries I have my worries like what
I don't know what the hell I just
watched at all really do you I haven't
pretty good concept of what we just
watched okay okay so I think she's going
missing she seems like some kind of like
a Lolita type thing because they keep
showing her with like scantily clad and
like blowing kisses and stuff but then
like is is Nicole Kidman's husband like
sneaking around with her or is he like
having an affair where what that no
that's that's the whole point is that
she's gone missing
okay and it's this is just pretty much
this psychological struggle that is that
what it's about is what it's doing to
these people over trying to find this
missing person okay I like mystery
suspense films like I do too last
kidnapping movie I saw was prisoners and
that was really good
have you seen that not so [ __ ] good
yeah it's another one that deals with
the psychological turmoil from a
kidnapping yeah no I appreciate
psychological turmoil I appreciate it
and I really like Nicole Kidman in
dramatic roles most of the time I really
I mean she looks like incredibly broken
shattered here which is incredible to
see in a film reminds me of her
performance and bewitched very similar
it
she reminds me of rabbit hole because
they remember they said rabbit hole came
out recently and that's my forte is all
about place she kind of seemed similar
in it then she didn't wrap it whole it
was that same like very sallow looking
like a mother figure who's just
tormented and who thinks her husband's
against her but I didn't really know
what to think of the girl the [ __ ]
girl who was missing I wasn't quite she
didn't seem really likable she I didn't
really I couldn't place it
I didn't say there was a piece of me
that was like are we glad that she's
whoa what I'm thinking is these are
flashbacks that are being told so might
not even be true it might not be as much
of a seductress little ho like they're
portraying yeah they're definitely you
know and it's got like a mystery about
it like are they gonna find her will she
be dead hey you know right is something
else gonna get out about like and I like
Hugo Weaving a lot to you yeah most of
the time most yeah yeah I guess so that
is how we're looking but I kind of weird
he's like southern and like charm that
totally British no I know but he looks
like like he has that southern charm you
know I like with the with the facial
hair and like kind of like skinny sunken
British or southern hair tight you know
so we're gonna give a rating now do
ratings okay I don't know if I'll
definitely go see it but I might go see
stranger labs
I would wait for it to come out on
Netflix okay and then I probably watch
it like if I was like flipping through
I'd be like oh yeah I saw that trailer
forever go on the channel with that guy
I think I'll watch that yeah one day
I'll remember my name
anyway if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and I'm gonna start promoting
this for Taylor right now we just talked
a lot about what you should do with a
YouTube channel and I like what week
it's not like hey you should just walk
like there's nothing else bloggers know
but let's face it a lot of people
there's some great vloggers out there
there are some grey vloggers and I just
I feel like that's usually the go-to
thing when you when someone feels like
they're not creative enough yeah but
she's really creative there's some
things in the pipeline that we have
ideas like videos from there are two
years old but check it out still well
don't be too harsh they're two years old
okay and in the description box you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
just to be straightforward I want to get
a certain amount of followers because I
want to do product placement like legit
product placement you know I know people
aren't supposed to talk about that but
Here I am today like we could tell you
what kind of remote this was if you had
enough subscribers but we can't mystery
yeah